music
Ian thank you thanks for inviting me to
do this this talk
um well initially I wanted to speak
actually about what the title suggests
right but when the organizers contacted
me and asked me to kind of give some
pedagogical introductory things so
actually I'm not going to speak for half
of the talk I'm not going to speak about
this uh how the talk is going to be an
interaction and then I will wish it to
this
another thing is not the new things here
is in the archive so please don't
pleasurize me
optimization
suppose I give you a set of polynomials
for well regarding some set of
non-commuting variables
was it standard and the canonical mpo
program is as follows you want to
minimize you want to minimize the
overlap between all the scalar product
between some some normalized vectors
space
with another Vector which is the result
of applying this
I was acting over this Vector with a
polynomial of these these variables we
have these operators among some set of
operators which satisfy this is the
polymer constraints
so this minimization is not only over
the set of all possible operators it is
five years constraints and not only over
this double possible Vector which are
normalized but also our all possible
hybrid spaces where these objects can be
defined
so does anybody follow I mean this is
really important so so why isn't the
little bit space fixed I mean no it's
not fixed yeah I mean imagine our
headboard space
so you're optimizing over all possible
keyword spaces uh operators and um or
matrices and and vectors
and normalized vectors so your only
input is the polynomial yeah these two
polynomials yes but this one is yeah so
you need to say how qcy is defined right
sorry how do you survive your
constraints can you survive yeah so
larger than zero movement what does this
means it means that when you when you
copy this polynomial of these operators
then you get some operator which is
positive semi-definite
and the variables are not her mission in
general so if you there's some Evolution
Associated to them
and the motivation is quantum I will go
to that because yeah you may wonder why
would anybody want to solve this monster
awesome great
kill yourself
great uh sorry my computer has blocked
uh okay yeah
okay so this kind of products have been
naturally in quantum chemistry for
example so suppose that you have an
anatom and an electron atom and you want
to calculate the minimum energy that
this atom can have now why because you
can repeat the same experiment
experience a subtracting one electron
and why is this important because the
difference between these two quantities
is the ionization potential of the atom
so this roughly tells you the amount of
energy you have to pump to this atom to
make it a illusion electron and it's a
very important chemical property out of
a really important stuff depend on this
of this number and the the job of many
most Quantum chemists is focused towards
calculating this number now but for that
of course you have to calculate first
these values here what are these values
how do you calculate them well you have
to compute the meaning of the overlap or
so normalized Vector activities of
Hilbert space with itself but multiply
by some quality polynomial of a set of
operators which satisfied this set of
anti-commutation relations
optimization problem
two matrices or operators
so this is so y a sub J minus x j is
whatever
okay the second problem I am going to
focus on is the characterization of
quantum correlations this was actually
the problem that boosted the really this
this line of research
and it is that you have two
experimentalists call them Alice and Bob
who are conducting experiments in
different sides of a building or
different planets but really really far
apart from each other and Alice calls
her experiment X number of course is
experiment Y and they obtain some
experimental results the A and B
so if Ali assemble repeat this
experience many times they can estimate
by frequency analysis the probability
that they obtain the results A and B
when they conduct experiments X and Y
now with this information Alice and Bob
would like to know if this this kind of
statistical information is compatible
with the fact that these two people are
living in a Quantum world because if it
is not it means that well there's
something really wrong about the way we
understand physics nowadays
now what does quantum mechanics tells
you quantum mechanics tells you that
each of these probabilities is the
overlap of some Vector defining some
Hillary space finite or Infinity
dimensional which is normalized with
itself and multiple multiplied by the
product of operators and these operators
are projectors so the squared is equal
to themselves right and they are also
for joint and this is why this set of
polynomial restrictions
so this is another example of a new
community polymer optimization problem I
give you these probabilities and I ask
you whether you can find a Quantum
realization
and it's a problem in both optimizations
or well okay I will go into that soon so
why is this problem important suppose
that indeed you you conduct some
experimental obtain some points and you
do not quite make sense of this point
you don't really understand I mean your
mathematical models do not really
explain why you got this distribution
could it be that you have a you're about
to refill quantum mechanics how could
you prove that
but ideally you have some good
characterization of the set of quantum
distributions which will allow you to
Define some weakness that would prove
that your point is on the wrong side of
the windows so you have repeated quantum
theory
now in practice or well or being
realistic you cannot expect to
characterize the quantum set it is still
an open program whether it is decided to
characterize this set
and the reason is that it's a really
difficult problem because you have to
prove that some distribution is not
Quantum you have to prove that doesn't
exist any Hebrew space finite or
infinite dimensional with a set of
operators that satisfying all these
relations is that this holds and this is
a problem that you cannot attack by
Brute Force if you start with fine
Dimensions you can only prove that
perhaps you cannot approximate the
distribution up to some Dimension 20
right and that being very optimistic but
they're discrete so so in that case it
can't really decided I mean if you take
if there are two values or something yes
no not really okay it depends if you
only take two values and also X and Y
only take two values and then it is
desirable someone slightly more
complicated right it's like the bells in
some generalization of bells
inequalities not all of them are decided
but it is not known about this problem
is designed in general
in this case I think
yes it is decidable because you can map
all this problem to a two-dimensional
problem so everything is decidable yes
but for three uh inputs whenever this
path is kind of conduct three different
types of experiments then it is believed
that you have to go to Infinity
Dimensions to reproduce all the
correlations
do we have actually some examples
okay so in case you kind of character as
you said you would like at least some
relaxation because Warrior trying to
produce at this point is not in the set
right so you really need to have some
efficient description or something which
is bigger than quantum mechanics this is
what you like to have optimally well
ideally then I guess a different way to
motivate the same thing is to say
instead of trying to refute random
mechanics you're trying to predict that
the result of an experiment will say
that this thing will be impossible to
achieve well yes okay yeah
and I'll wait to view it okay now this
example for Quantum information reveals
that these products are kind of
difficult because involve optimizations
or finite and infinite dimensional
keyword spaces and this problem is this
problem is in general so difficult as to
the point of being undecidable in
general this problem known to be
undecidable this is known to be
understandable yes they're the general
problem and I will I will speak again
finite situation finite
the qis
this problem is undecidable
what does it follow from I mean okay
yeah no so it is only settled because
you can call the code the word problem
into it and what is the word problem and
the word problem I give you a set of an
alphabet a finite alphabet which you
have to interpret as the generators of a
group that I'm going to Define now
and the definition of the group is
gained by a set of words that you
promise that are equal to the identity
so this defines a single group and then
the word problem is simply I give you
some other word and I ask if it is equal
to the identity
now this problem is not to be
undecidable because you can I don't call
it halting problem
now the relation between this and the
non-conductive polymer optimization is
that if you give me some instance of the
word problem I can always take this word
that you give me and express it as a
product of variables then add the the
adjoint the hermitian conjugate and they
subtract two and then I enter to
optimize overall possible variables
which are which are unitary
and says that all the words are equal to
the identity
now the solution of this problem if this
word is indeed equal to one so this
should be equal to zero because then you
have here the identity plus the identity
minus two so you have zero
on the other hand if it is not equal to
one I can give you some representation
of this group for which this problem is
at most -2 so what this shows is that
you cannot expect to compute these
values to solve NPO problems and not
even approximately
well uh okay and yet with a measure
project to to realize that they're
actually systematic methods to attack
this problem and you can solve it okay
and I will got into that soon no all
these methods are essentially start from
the same idea so you have um DVS to
replace the monomials of these these
variables by some by some concept of
complex numbers that you call momenta so
for each monomial here let's say X1 I'm
going to associate some momentum so
momentum y X1
now I will say that each of these
moments of momentum it's an operator
representation if you can find some
human space and some operators acting on
the silver space satisfying all these
restrictions it says that each of these
momentas is present this form
now of course this is just a way a
simple way to reformulate the mpo
problem right as a linear optimization
over the set of all complex numbers
which have with an operator
representation I'm just repeating what I
now how do you solve this problem it is
to define a as I said you cannot expect
to characterize this set completely so
what you do instead is to define a
hierarchy of sdp relaxations that well
converts in the apps is the hypnotic
limit to this set
all right
okay and the fact that you can assure
the word problem translates into some
some prediction here namely that you
cannot find bands for the speed of
components of this hierarchy
good
um okay so how does hierarchy work
okay so give us a set of complex numbers
how could you could you try to what are
the necessary conditions for these
things to emit an operator
representation well an easy condition is
simply that while the sub 1 is equal to
Identity and this is all for
normalization from your vector
a more complicated condition is to well
you use all this momentum to Define some
Matrix which is labeled by the the words
or sorry of the the monomials of the
non-community variables and such that
the V8 WTF entry is given by this
expression and it's very easy to prove
that um the if your set of complex
numbers and it's an operator
representation this Matrix might be
positive semi-definite and well it's so
easy that I will put it now
if you multiply by some arbitrary Vector
set and you replace the definition and
then here it is line you use the fact
that this thing up needs an operator
representation then you can simply carry
this this sum here and we double your
sum here and you end up with some Vector
types itself
okay well in another way for each of
these constraints here you have to
Define some localizing matrix it's going
to create a localizing matrices which
are also linear combinations of these
things and you can as well prove that if
this set of momentum is an operator
representation then these things will be
possibly semi-definite good so the
reaction I propose is very simple really
I mean rather optimizing over all
possible vectors and I meet an operator
representation I'm going to optimize for
all possible moment vectors which such
as y1 is equal to one and the moment a
local asymmetric is
the sdp hierarchy
no because it's a relaxation of course
it gives you some lower bound on the
solution of the problem and is this
extension of normative extension of the
archimed and condition holds maybe that
you can find some positive numbers C
such that this polynomial here is the
sum of the scores then you can prove
convergence and what what this thing is
telling you simply is that the structure
of these Qi says is such that you can
prove that it's these variables are
bounded operators
good so now I have to make an
observation
or a pallo gets angry
so here here you have the standard mpo
problems suppose that we add this extra
condition that all the or personal
variables commute
then this reduces to a standard
polynomial minimization problem in which
you're trying to minimize important
email or some complex variables in some
region of a complex plane given by this
these polynomials
and then if you apply the hierarchy that
I put you have to add this extra
condition namely that's a momentum
regarding the same word that with data
is permitted are the same and then you
end up with the laser parallel hierarchy
for polynomial minimization
now this is very beautiful but how does
this work does it perform well in
practice
but for Quantum I'm going to show you
numbers because I think we point to this
and we are an expert in these things
you're I mean I think it really matters
so you went on chemistry the method
Works quite well actually the first
level so the hierarchy are called reduce
the cinematics theory in quantum
chemistry and it was just Pioneer by
Nakata his collaborators who I believe
they also introduced for the first time
the use of symmetry programming in go to
chemistry it has proven very useful to
fine ground state already so very
accurate approximation studies of small
molecules
using these reduce density Matrix stuff
in much older right yeah so what kind of
cons I mean they were not using semi
definitely problems and what were they
well in these papers they used to make
any programs I know before yeah both no
they mentioned approximation using
linear programming and uh well I don't
know I had a look once and yeah it was
really nasty
okay
for Quantum information this uh this
hierarchy uh well actually it has been
quite successful because it is so far
the only way we know to bound this set
in a systematic way so now thanks to
this hierarchy because when you trans
you apply all this hierarchy to this
problem then what you get is a sequence
of sets of correlations that converts
this to the quantum set and it's which
contains it so if you give me some point
which is not Quantum and eventually will
be detected by some level of the
hierarchy
now I have to be honest with you this
program of mine of trying to review
quantum theory hasn't gone very far yet
but uh okay happy to say to say that at
least it's hierarchy fund applications
in other areas like for example in
device independent Quantum cryptography
or Randomness amplification of substance
name of quantum devices in all these
three subjects you need to bound this
set of correlations from the outside
right and for this thing this is this
kind of Handy
okay finally so I can just pick our new
material good so the idea is I want to
put some restriction on the Hillary
spacer where this optimization is being
carried up and in particular I'm going
to impose that uh what I'm going to put
about the dimension of this here
workspace now
the reason why I want to well I want to
give you two reasons to to solve this
problem is the computation of quantum
dimensional Witnesses
media and these people the purpose is
protocol in which some parties is
producing some states draw X from where
X radius from one to n or B levels and
then he sends it to some measurement
device and the measurement device has
input one buttons so you press one of
this button why and you get some result
there zero one so the statistics of this
experiment or the physical description
is given by this probably is the
probability obtained the result B when
we prepare the state X the quantum is
State X and we press the button the
button y
now you could think of all the
distributions that you can generate with
d level systems call it QD
and then what we propose in this paper
is given some direction this probability
space that you you tend to optimize
linearly over these things
the result is a dimensional damage sorry
the dimension plot the witness
and the idea of this paper is that if
you conduct some experiment in this kind
of scenario and you obtain some point
which is in the wrong side on the wrong
side of the of the witness
then you are proving that your contact
technology allows you to manipulate
Quantum systems of Dimension at least D
plus one which is non-trivial because
now there's some emergence of different
Quantum Technologies right and we don't
really know what they do we have some
theoretical models which of course have
nothing to do with what people observe
in practice and when somebody tells you
I can control three level assistance
well you have to it should be subject to
something like this
okay of course if this the problem of
this set is that it seems to be very
difficult to characterize so for this
kind of experience you would like to
have at least some good relaxation of a
set
now these are similar well it's exactly
the same mathematically exactly the same
scenario but people in more computer
science oriented Quantum communication
complexity so in this problem
are two parties who are separated and
they are distributed to strings of bits
and then they want to calculate some
some functions of binary function of
these two strings of Bits And there are
lots of communication from alistaba
miscommunication is in the form of a d
level Quantum system
and these two problems you can formulate
them as a new community polymer
optimization problem with some
Dimensions so it's the same problem
function here
yeah but for some reason people working
condomination with the services people
working Quantum communication are
computer scientists and they don't talk
to each other with each other's paper so
it took a lot of time for them to
realize that it was they were speaking
about the same
good so you solve this problem
because we work in the same field we're
all working Quantum information is
embarrassing the theory of communication
yes
okay so how can you solve this problems
an obvious method would be to decompose
it and see variable into some Matrix of
different complex entries and then I use
classical problem minimization problem
and then you apply the last parallel
hierarchy the problem is that when
people have tried to do that for the
class of problems that you can find find
normal economic information you you
should hold it to memory requirements
and I believe the reason is that the LA
Superior hierarchy is just too General
because it's easily for for optimization
of whatever right and in the structural
Market multiplication not all doesn't
seem to depend on all possible monomials
of the of the entries of the Matrix for
example here multiply a matrix by itself
are a mission Matrix you can see that
there's some monomies who are missing
from from this from the result right so
this more or less what the reason why I
think that you know hierarchy would be
like tend to kill a fly without
a machine gun or something no
uh
okay the initial relaxation will be
given the dimension if you want a good
approximation that is true yeah I mean
yeah the best reason compromise
okay
um okay yeah to solve this problem is
as follows so as before I go to map this
program into finding some linear
optimization of some kind of complex
number released in the complex how of
the vector which I mean an operator
representation that with a body
dimensionality
good so I'm going to give a high level
description of the algorithm and then
well okay so first of all you start with
some variable JL you update it to one
then you generate some set of random
matrices X1 the a2x and J in a motion
complex and completely random and also
some random Vector in the same space
which is normalized
next you use these matrices and this
Vector to build a moment Vector using
expectation values in a very useful way
and then you update the value of J then
you repeat
can you repeat and repeat until the one
back to the generate in the GX iteration
is a linear combination of the previous
ones
when we reach that point any moment
Vector with an operator representation
will be a linear combination of the
previews that you generated
if you want you to just like a random
Vector as a random moment vector and it
happens to be a linear combination that
is that you generated it means
it means simply that any random Vector
any any moment Vector will will be
adding a combination of the things that
you generated it doesn't really take
much to
you simply have a Subspace which you
don't have an explicit yes an explicit
basis for so you're just sampling random
elements
and presumably you if the substances
Dimension
M then you only need to sample M of them
and then yeah then the M plus one then
ultrasound you'll find It's a
combination of the other ones I mean
this this algorithm is probably able
this is some some Randomness right
actually you can make it completely
deterministic but then it's more
difficult to program you can use like um
orthogonal polynomials and everything
works fine right but
we've started that in practice this is
much easier to code
to solve anything this is just
this
yeah there is a four monomials is too
too huge one heuristic that I mentioned
so you're restricting two ways
random Subspace or or no no no there's
the thing so the software that you have
generated this way is this independent
of how you sample these vectors
so why you cannot compute this
experience you can compute it explicitly
you can I mean you can use orthogonal
polynomials and you can compute
explicitly but it's more difficult and
more difficult to code and I think well
I don't know
um this is this is simply easier to
easier to program I would say yeah
pretty generous
well what sorry very generally to
explain any Subspace that you can suffer
from yeah yeah no it's not a special
property of these things but I have to
identify this half space
okay so your hip relaxation is like the
one we had before with the mpo but we
have now this extra constraint that the
moment Vector has to be linear
combination of the things that we
generated and that's the only the only
constraint there's the only part where
the dimension plays a role
now I say that this is a high level
description because if you try to
program then you put this to your
machine then your HTTP server will tell
you to go to hell
and the reason is that sometimes when
you generate randomly these things
you'll find more investors which are
very similar to each other and it's
really bad so you want to implement this
I give you two tips the first tip is
that as you generate the moment Vector
you have to you have to compute the
associated moment matrixes and also the
the localizing matrices and then you
regard them as vectors using the um the
hebrewsmith product
Now using rather say you generate some
orthonormal basis and
yeah alphabet as well of course it will
satisfy these restriction right and this
is actually what you put in the program
so instead of rather than putting this
constraint here you replace
um the positive well
yeah intuitively uh you're you're
replacing the the moment a localized
images by this other block diagonal
matrix set and assassins so you're
Computing this Subspace yes and you're
saying and somehow you have this
parameter which is the dimension of your
keyboard space yes so what changes of
these Subspace as you change the
dimension I mean did I mention changes
yeah the sound space itself
I mean did I mention as a function of
this
yes yeah no
but yeah I mean if you fix that the
other relaxation right and you start
increasing the dimension at some point
you get a maximum and then yeah
no but I don't understand how I'm not
the ambient Dimension right the Y itself
lives in the same Dimension but it's a
bigger Subspace inside this Dimension
yes the the span of the of everything
that could be that could be derived from
the dimension D operators is smaller
than what could be the rightful
Dimension to The Operators yes
yeah sure
he said to me is very fast actually yeah
but of course it has to surgery because
this is
okay
okay uh what okay but essentially you're
you're just writing the program in a
different way right and if you if you
feed this thing to your solver and in
the solver it happens to be selumi then
it won't protest that much but it hits
any other software it will protest
because this problem by construction
doesn't have feasible so extremely
feasible Solutions
so my second tip as well as this problem
is as you generate the the random moment
vectors and you start constructing these
matrices you start adding the map and
you'll end up with something that
depends on the way you assemble the you
sample the vectors
but most importantly the support of this
thing will not depend on the way you you
sample them so yes it could be some
isometry to the support of this dme3
Matrix
and actually this is why your program so
rather than an imposing this constraint
impose this other one and this this by
construction has a strictly feasible
solution it's exactly logically it's
exactly the same problem but this is
something that we saw we
observe that servers like
good okay
well because we're optimizing our subset
or sorry a superset of the of the set of
all uh things that are in the complex
cell of the
of the problem
if the communion condition is satisfied
I can promise you that the sequential
lower bounds we convert and actually I
don't even need the archimedia
conditions so we can innovate it will be
enough but I won't get into that I got
this plane
briefly why this is the case why do you
have convergence
let's introduce this concept that maybe
perhaps many of you know about this but
I heard about this for the first time
three years ago and I couldn't believe
it
polynomial identities have some
polynomials of matrices which are equal
to zero for as long as you feed them
with medicines which are given a given
size about this size
now for example in dimensional one one
of these mpis would be this one would be
a commutator because everything in
damage on one commute in dimension two
is you have this funny example that is
also equal to zero right for all matches
of Dimension two and this is the reason
is that the square of the commutator of
any two matrices in dimension two is
proportional to Identity therefore has
to commit with anything else
but of course if you generate like three
random batteries of Dimension three this
thing will be equal to zero so the
sanotrivial relation
well the message one and two are not are
not special so for any Dimension you can
find some medicine polynomial identities
that is equal to zero for matrices of
Dimension D but Lexis symmetrics and
dimension D plus one which allows you to
violate this constraint
okay so now I can speak a little bit
proof of convergence
you take your program you start running
it and then you get a sequence of
solution you run it for all possible
orders and you get a sequence of
minimizes for this program
now supposedly their Canadian condition
holds and then by using
you can prove that from this sequence of
minimizes there's a subsequence that
converges entry wise to some infinite
dimensional moment Vector which is a
feasible for all possible or less of a
relaxation
Now using the genus construction you saw
that from this Vector you can construct
some Hilbert space and some operators we
satisfy all these identities sorry all
these relations also you can find some
normalized vectors such that each of the
elements is given but has the formula
you should have
and also because of the way you
constructed this thing you know that all
these operators that you have generated
are constructed satisfy all matches
polymer identities for Dimension d
now you can see the algebra that this
element is generate and then this
efferent by phone number that tells you
that you can you can kind of block
diagonalize it into some direct integral
of factors and there are three types of
factors factors of type 1 are more or
less like um like B of H and if one of
these factors were of type 1 then we
know that you couldn't have a
dimensional greater than D because then
it would buy you could prove that these
things would violation Matrix polynomial
identity
now it could be also a factor of type 2
and 2 and 3 in principle but actually
cannot because in this case is a bit
more complicated but you will show that
if that were the case you could also you
could also manage would be able to uh to
allow these things to violate or
somebody's polynomial identity
so the result is that you can block
diagonalize all these operators into
blocks that have the dimension mostly
so here you're keeping V fix and taking
K to Infinity
okay so with these two conditions the
fact that you can block diagonal as The
Operators and then you're obtaining your
numbers this way and also if some block
diagonal operators decide these things
so of course each of the blocks will
also be positive semi-definite right
then what you find is that the vector
that you the this limit Vector is the
convex is in the compact sound the
vector which emitter operator
representation and therefore uh well
this limit is at the zero point
okay so how does this thing work in
practice uh here I have to apologize
because I still do not have that many
numerical results right and recently I
discovered I was coding the things in a
very sub-optimal way but anyway I'm
going to
so we try to apply first all these ideas
to this problem the problem where Alice
is allowed to Bob a system of Dimension
too and they're trying to maximize some
the accommodation of probabilities
and you have two types of variables and
this is what my mistake was actually one
of them is is uh there are they are like
uh unitary and the other types they are
they are projectors
now instead of applying a method that I
just described I'm going to apply a
variant
so because it is very easy to sample
from random uniters and random
projectors in dimension too so right
under sampling from arbitrary matrices
we sample yeah random uniters random
projectors and use them to construct
this bow and vectors so in my vectors
will satisfy a set of extra constraints
that would enforce that you actually do
not need for this problem and localizing
matrices the monument is enough
memory and it's fine
uh okay so what we find is that in the
second order of relaxation we already
found tight bounce for the
for the inequalities purpose here so in
this paper The Proposal inequalities or
several witnesses and they use
variational methods to find lower bounds
on the maximal value but they could
improve if these bounds were optimal and
when these techniques you can
and to my analysis we're the first one
who got this
were supplied not exactly the method I
described by some variant of it to the
product finding no local dimensional
weaknesses and it is what I thought
before you have to part disconnecting
measurements and you want to
characterize the distribution so they
can generate already put some bound on
the dimension of the systems that they
have access to
okay so again you have to solve well
what seems like an NPO problem but now
you have this extra constraint that the
algebra of observables or one party and
the other must be like equivalent to
some B of H of from where the dimension
of these huberous places is bounded by
the uh it's a problem that you can also
attack similarly so what we do in these
cases again we Generate random
projectors because our variables have
projectors
and it's a random vector and then we
build the ammo and Vector but here
because we have to make sure that these
two these and the F's commute is the
condition here
rather than Computing products we first
ensure that it is with the identity and
then the identity with the F's in order
to ensure that these two things compute
now you may think that I'm introducing
extra assumption here but uh I'm
actually not because in finite
Dimensions you can kind of interchange
computational relations with potential
products so in the end in the end the
social relaxation or the initial problem
and with these ideas we started studying
situations where you have eight
non-commutative variables normative term
trivial variables
in MSS two and three
and we obtained results for k equals two
and a question Dimension two and k
equals three in the case of Dimension
three in normal desktop so this is
something that well lowering Quantum
information have been able to give you
an approximate I had a paper where I had
a similar hierarchy of sdps right and we
managed to to go like here to get some
approximations in dimension two but not
tie downs but these three three things
like a new word for us
that's just ridiculous but really I
don't know it's kind of difficult
now this is one of the reasons why we
couldn't go that much fire was because
we're not exploiting match the
symmetries of the problem because
sometimes the objective function has
some symmetries and you can use this to
reduce the complexity so talking to them
and based on the the way it seems to
scale this is the stagness for this
family of bounds I will try I believe
that you should be able to damage to six
would be a attainable with a normal
computer in with
foreignty enough
okay I know I know we also I won't also
want to apply it and I'm still now
calling this to what I call hybrids
finding infinite dimensional
optimization
and it is this time you have three
experimentalists conducting measurements
but you bound the dimension of one of
them but you let the other the other two
be free
so now the problem you have to solve is
a problem with yes it's anal Community
polymer optimization problem and the
other one of the part is the other
neurology is is kind of constrained to
have a dimension constraint but the idea
about these two are not so here you
cannot apply the Lesser parallel
hierarchy because here you really are
optimizing or infinite dimensional
Hilbert spaces
okay uh well okay
similar idea
okay so finally
um I want to speak really briefly about
how complex is to to run these these
codes right because the way I told you
how to run is is not optimal and it
would be uh would be a mistake to try to
use it if you want to really high or
this other relaxation and solution is
the following for a normal NPO problem
because nothing comes with anything the
this number of monomials of your
variables increase exponentially within
this of the relaxation and so that's the
the size of the moment and localizing
matrices and the number of three
variables that you have
however using some ideas from condos
matter Theory the concept of Matrix for
other states thermocol Laboratories and
I prove that you can actually expand
these matrices and also even this Vector
into a a space of a polynomial size and
the vectors that you're using to expand
it are such that you can calculate
overlaps very quickly so you can make
this expansion really really fast and
this allows you to compress this is
exactly your approximation exactly it's
exactly yeah and what are we assuming
about your polynomials I mean the the
local the polynomials that you have or
or the ones they use device or no no no
they can be water no no no nothing
relaxation that you want to use
you can you can relate on Matrix
polynomial inequalities to uh to a
mattress product state so it is another
way of representing the trivial bound
right like
but it still gives you a savings I don't
understand are you choosing he's
choosing the band Dimension like he's
optimizing over everything with one
dimension K exactly with no particular
guarantee that it gives you the right
date
uh what do you mean no like like you you
optimize over things in one dimension K
that doesn't mean that it gives you that
it necessarily the goal of the problem
is to optimize
so I mean let me know
like okay it's not DK is nothing okay
case independentality I'm click here and
fixing D and then uh just going to
different orders of the relaxation well
I'm so confused but maybe no it should
be that well you can prove that you can
expand these things with matches for
other states and the thing is that the
the the span of magic product stays uh
the the space that they expand does not
grow exponentially with a number of
sites it grows it grows polynomial with
a number of sites
because I'm repeating the same tensor
this is the same this is the same idea
this is the dimension is still
exponential you're just saying that you
can span you can find a small set of
generators for this
when you're not changing the dimension
yeah actually I'm changing the dimension
because when I project into these basis
and then it reduces automatic is to have
poly k
o I'm confused but but we can talk about
it can explain you
are easier to deal with than infinity
dimensions one year ago in Quantum
information size we're not sure about
this because the tools we had for
infinite Dimensions to be to optimize
for Infinity Dimensions were much better
than the tools we had to optimize in
dimension too so we didn't really
understand what was going on
okay so in conclusion well here I
presented some converting sdp hierarchy
for NPO and the dimensional constraints
I've argued very quickly although maybe
we can discuss it this polymer
complexity of this hierarchy future
workbook if you have any problems we
have matrices once the fields conversion
okay the good thing now I'm really
excited about this this problem I think
it's because I think it's the closest to
science fiction I will never be too so
here I want to distinguish between
having a system of unbounded Dimension
but finally Dimension a system of
infinity dimensions and it is the follow
we don't have any promise here in the
dimension
okay but I want to conduct this
optimization
I want to optimize her give you some set
of constraints I want to optimize for
all possible finite dimensional
representations
and I don't have the latest idea about
how to attack this program in general I
have some ideas about how to attack it
for some families of of um of mpo
problems for those families I can give
you non-trivial constraints which take
away some of the infinite dimensional
systems but while keep keeping the the
final dimensions
kind of kind of so I mean okay one of
the motivation is mathematical but the
main motivation is to live out of people
unemployed because
I would like to use these tools to
device from experiment that you can do
in the lab but which cannot be explained
with finite dimensional quantum
mechanics and there are many people in
in Quantum from quantum gravity
Community who have a lot of models which
do not make sense in Infinity Dimensions
so if you perform this experiment and
you were successful then you would lead
all these people unemployed
that person okay with this I want to and
thank you
questions
so you have this polynomial in the
polynomials that are satisfied by you
know all matrices of Dimension 17 or
less
I assume you can show that there's no
polynomial
that's Satisfied by all matrices of
phonic Dimension but not satisfied by
infrint dimensional what other doesn't
exists right so it's known that such
yeah yeah
it seems like it's a very well developed
theory of Pi objects
there's a
we saw the hits
these are these are things that Dr
Christ have studied
yeah no there's a theorem that says that
uh for Dimension D the the degree of the
smallest polynomial that is a multiple
identity it has to be 2D
wait what about that's a dominant like
expression that's the episode
yes yeah exactly yes
yes so that seems like a possible
barrier to your your goal right no no I
can uh
I can
we can discuss it right but I can really
show you some relaxing which are not
trivial
dagger
oh well well you do have yeah
dimensional
is not a good example because it's
yeah
is a good example because you're not
bounded and therefore I mean you're not
exactly measuring them right but no
worries but you have you take two of
them you can find boundary operators I
have this decided relations for example
which it can be done in finite
dimensions of course because if you took
the trace and you have zero here and
then some numbers here here no it's a
little more subtle than that because
this this thing for example doesn't have
any single defining dimensional
representation so it doesn't make sense
to optimize for five Dimensions but I
can give you a sets of identities which
have final dimensional representations
and I can I have a way to get rid of
some of the infinity dimensional
representations while keeping all the
find it
questions
thank you